these are comments coming from Margarita
de la Val she became chief executive of
Vodafone at the beginning of the month
having been the interim chief executive
for uh five months before that prior to
that she was also Chief Financial
Officer so when she's criticizing uh
past performance there's an element of
self-criticism in that herself because
she's been a very established member of
the Vodafone board for quite a while but
as you say the headline is that 11 000
jobs are going to be going over the next
three years to put that into context
Vodafone employees at the end of last
year some 104 000 people globally
there's been no real indication as to
where the ax is going to fall other than
uh for Vodafone to say that it will
probably be a mixture of headquarters
jobs and across local markets and the
backdrop to this case that really
vodafone's performance over many many
years now has been pretty stagnant its
biggest Market is Germany the UK is
actually only its third largest market
these days even though it is a a UK
listed company and of course founded in
Newbury in Berkshire which is where a
lot of employees still work but the
markets in which it competes chiefly
Germany but also the UK Italy Spain they
are all incredibly competitive there
hasn't been the same sort of
consolidation in the mobile market that
we've seen in some other economies
around the world and it's something that
Vodafone has been pressing for itself
for many years and in fact it's
currently in on off talks right now with
three UK potentially about bringing
together its UK business with that of
three UK but really margins in the
sector are very very low the financial
performance has as I say this is not a
new thing it's been a lackluster
performance for quite a while now it's a
return on Capital invested at times has
not even met its cost of capital in
other words uh it's it's that is not a
metric that you want to be a look at
very closely Margarita de la Val really
aiming to put that right the company
reported its full year results today by
the way underlying earnings uh during
the course of the efl by 1.3 which
really speak thanks to the fact that
this is a very competitive field indeed
in which it's playing